[Music]
hey guys this is
congratulations
[Music]
what's up guys hey how you doing uh i
just want to get this out of the way
uh for everyone watching this on youtube
uh for the next 24 hours
there is domestic free shipping
on everything storewide crystallia.com
so go to crystallia.com
storewide domestic shipping is free
okay for the next 24 hours if you're a
patreon subscriber
you also get a 15 discount
and i gave you guys a code over on
patreon
that the people who are listening to on
youtube don't have
so go watch it on patreon and get that
code
and you get also 15 off of your entire
order
so and if you're not on patreon then go
sign up for patreon and then you can get
entire whatever you guys get it you know
i'm not a
what does he say i'm not a businessman
i'm a businessman
same thing uh anyway uh i'm not a
businessman
i'm a business man i'm not a businessman
i'm a businessman same thing
i get it so don't come after me but
still same thing
i'm not a dairy queen i'm a dairy queen
i went to shoprite and shopped wrong
dude one time
i was in new jersey because that's where
i come from and um
there was this girl you know how like
dude it's sad man when you're like in
in elementary school there's that one
person that is made fun of
and they always they always grow up to
be like uh
who's that guy uh on the [ __ ]
renegade shows
the [ __ ] that really sexy dude eric
something probably his name's [ __ ]
eric something who knows dude what's his
name dude lorenzo llamos that's what it
is
that's a real guy lorenzo lamas and uh
that you know but there's always a
person in elementary school that's been
made fun of the most
and one time omar pitts one of my
buddies
said that it's about jessica
jessica was the one i got made fun of i
hope she's doing well but everyone made
fun of her i'm not me i didn't do that i
always felt bad and um baltimore pit
said jessica went to shop right and
shopped wrong
and i always [ __ ] think of that and i
laughed and i laughed and there's no
shop right
in la so i can't do that to my friends
in l.a
so anyway um yeah so
i'm not a dairy queen i'm a dairy queen
that's that's very stupid that's not f
that's not that funny um so
uh you know we're real we do we say real
[ __ ] sometimes the bits work sometimes
they don't but i feel like
i feel like it does kind of work a
little bit you know i don't know dude
you guys like podcasts some people are
like i [ __ ] don't like your stand up
i like your podcast i like your pockets
i don't like your stand up some people
you know what it is i think you just
like podcasts
you ever [ __ ] sit in the front row of
a stand-up comedian show and you watch
the stand-up comedian you just like see
their face you could hear their face
that's like i used to say about the
newscasters when you do the news
you do the news early in the morning
when you were doing um like when i was
traveling and i would have to do the
[ __ ] uh
uh press about my shows coming up yeah
come out to see me the funny bone in
[ __ ] ohio
and um and
uh the newscasters would like ask me a
question and then they'd lean in and i
would just be staring at their face and
i would just be like wow this is [ __ ]
incredible that their face is so close
and i could see their pores and i could
hear them like
you know what i mean and they say oh boy
that's just great isn't it no matter
what you say
literally you'll be like yeah i killed a
dog on the way here oh that's just great
isn't it
so chris is gonna be live at the [ __ ]
uh
funny bone in
akron ohio which uh
we didn't know was a place until we
drove by and my wife wanted to live here
so i had to become a [ __ ]
newscaster in akron ohio it's all good i
don't harbor resentment
um so yeah dude i was in [ __ ] uh
arizona and uh
it was crazy
that's it it was absolutely crazy i was
there in arizona
for two weeks just chilling
um and uh we brought the we
obviously brought the kid we don't leave
him when we go somewhere we bring him
and we pack him up like he's a suitcase
dude
we bring him is that crazy your life
just changes you bring a kid i gotta
bring your kid everywhere
and so we did uh we went to uh
arizona it was cool uh family trip
visited um kristen's mom
and we were chilling and
it was fine dude i i i i thought i was
gonna go
be losing my mind for two weeks doing
nothing and then i realized
i've been doing nothing for a really
long time and just kind of hanging out
so i just use those tools
i sat in [ __ ] arizona and i used
those tools to just sit be bored and
have peace with myself now i wasn't
bored because i was the people i love
but
you know what i mean and um and also it
got a little bit exciting too because
uh number one i killed a scorpion
because i had to because he was near my
son
i [ __ ] stepped on him didn't know uh
what i stepped on i said that might have
been a scorpion and then
um kristen's uncle says oh it could have
been let me go see
let me go see i'll get the i'll get the
blue the black light and i didn't even
know
that if you just [ __ ] shine a black
light on a scorpion
that [ __ ] brightens the [ __ ] up
dude
like brightens up brightens up like it's
a [ __ ] spider-man villain like you
just
put a flashlight on it at night and it's
it looks like one of those halloween
stickers
and and he put it on the blood and guts
and sure enough he's like oh yeah that's
a that's a that's a scorpion look it's
it was like all [ __ ] neon across the
sidewalk
and i was like wow i saved my son's life
go figure i saved my son's life
yeah dude then i got in a loop and i was
like what if the scorpion stung him and
i thought about that for an hour and i
was definitely disassociating and not
not being present with the family anyway
um
dude sometimes it just takes a little
bit like that to just trip you up and
you're just out of the [ __ ] and you're
like dude i'm out you know what i'm out
how about that how about that
i thought how about this i thought about
family members diane how about you guys
play yahtzee and i'm out how about that
how about i just kill the scorpion and
thought what if i didn't and it stung my
son and he had to go into the icu
and how about i'll just be thinking
about that for the next two hours
and how about you guys play ghazi okay
because no matter what dude if i'm just
like this i'm just like this yeah but
we're just all fortunate aren't we
because we're living and you never know
you gotta take it one day at a time
oh two sixes um should i count it for my
doubles or whatever the [ __ ] you got
yahtzee dude games games games
[Music]
games dude
all games you got your cards like little
[ __ ] asses
you got them all did you see did nobody
saw him right
yeah you got it okay who's gonna who's
turned it whose turn is it to [ __ ]
run the role that does it matter
what do you mean well everyone gets a
chance does it matter well this way you
decide to who's not cheating
who's not cheating dude
games [ __ ]
blow chunks how about that dude i'll
take it way back to elementary school
games blow chunks
i try though i try to play them and i
try to have fun and i try to actually
imagine myself
having a fun time during the game and
then you know the other [ __ ] people
who say like
yeah smiles smile more and then you'll
smile more
like you know people are like that make
yourself pretend smile and it'll turn
into a real smile and also smiling burns
more calories than frowning
you know people will say that like
you're just gonna be some jackass
walking around the street just like
that's not gonna turn into a real smile
that's gonna turn into
you're real alone people are scared of
that guy
hey why is that guy [ __ ] weirdly
smiling outside of mel's diner
i'm working on my real smile why is that
guy
pretend smiling outside of [ __ ]
what's that one place burger him
oh i'm working on my real smile oh a
crazy person you know a smile kills more
calories than [ __ ] frowning
um so yeah so i killed a scorpion
scoop that up as a memory put that in my
back pocket oh hey your boy's 41
not really a crazy outdoorsy guy you
know he wears tie-dye
which means he's not very outdoorsy
unless he's in like a [ __ ]
a a desert with a bunch of hippies but i
don't even i don't do that
and i'm not a guy who's an outdoorsy guy
that's near bears either at all
or in any woods or desert or just give
me all the walls
around me i'm good have the walls in my
house
we built the house we figured out how to
make all these great technologies
i'll be chilling near there because we
figured it out right
oh you invented that thank you i'll use
it i'm not the guy who's
so i never even [ __ ] seen a scorpion
except for inside a what
a pet store at the mall right say it
with me so um
saw one killed it and uh that was that
and um so i did that and then also
that wasn't the only killing going on in
the arizona trip
because my dog chenzo aka
trash dog all of a sudden we hear
in one of the back in the backyard they
don't not yard it's like rocks in
arizona they don't have there's like no
grass because the water bill is like
four
four thousand dollars a month to keep it
because everything's so dry
the second you walk into arizona or
drive into arizona your lips are just
like
and you try to you try to take a [ __ ]
your next bowel movement's just
nothing comes out it's just like me up
that's what comes out just that air
ha that's what comes out your butthole
dude what are you gonna take
did we talk about the hard-hitting
issues here but you go to take a [ __ ]
in arizona not the first [ __ ] the first
[ __ ] you still have the
the [ __ ] stacked from wherever you were
when that one releases
and then you eat whatever you eat and
then that one brews it comes out and it
just goes
ha that's what happens all right
um and your lips go hot and you just
your lips are bleeding while you're just
your asshole's doing vocal warm-ups just
a bleeding ass lip and your [ __ ] ass
is going
mayo mayo mayo mayo
[Laughter]
dude vocal exercises dude i used to be
in chorus
when i was in the eighth grade and uh mr
kelsey
rest in peace he died of cancer but
anyway who am i my mom
anyway um he uh he always had uh he
would always go
here we go we're doing the scales and he
would go mayo mayo
and then and normally you go mayo mayo
mayo mayo
[Applause]
but he would [ __ ] kill it he would do
like an extra like [ __ ] you i've
i've been practicing for a long time and
i've done this for years
and you [ __ ] ain't got [ __ ] on
me students so he would go
[Applause]
like he would [ __ ] use the last part
with the first part that guy
killed it dude and we'd all try to do it
as students and we were just like
we're we're and um
anyway dude he died of cancer but
we all will someday and uh
oh cool just got a [ __ ] thing on my
computer that said remind me later
that said you want you want to install
this remind me later definitely just get
a virus
um so um anyway that wasn't the only
killing going on because chen's
a trash dog
all of a sudden wow i almost vomited did
you hear that we'll keep that in
and uh he um
we hear in the backyard which is not a
yard rocks
what the [ __ ] is going on chens and we
look
and we see
chenzo with a bloody mouth
and then we see behind him like he's
trying to be like nothing to see here
a [ __ ] pigeon belly up
trying to flap upside down when you flap
you get higher
that pigeon was upside down flapping
which just means he was trying to dig
into the ground he was just trying to
hurry to hell because he didn't want
[ __ ] he didn't want
chen's eating them anymore
and he had a bloody beard like he was a
[ __ ] game of thrones
character like winter already had done
come
and he uh and he
[ __ ] was just we were like no get the
[ __ ] no no
and he ran inside and then and then
crystal was like just leave the pigeon
and we're like what and she's like leave
the pigeon i'm gonna call a pigeon place
i'm just like what's a pigeon place just
step on it to put out of its misery it's
dead almost
she's like i'm just gonna call a pigeon
put someone called a vet
and they'll know what to do and person's
mom is googling what to do when a
pigeon's dead upside down and your
[ __ ] rocks
and your back rocks and um
and and everyone's just got their own
way of well
what we'll do is this and that and we'll
do this maybe it'll just be okay and
then
and then kristen walks outside and she's
like i don't know i didn't really look
but i didn't really see it maybe it flew
away
and then like more time passes by and
then we let the dogs out to pee
and then upsy daisy you could guess the
end of the story we are
like what the [ __ ] hey chens and we look
at for chens and chen says
under a cactus
with a headless pigeon and the pigeon is
headless
because chens has the head of the pigeon
in his bloody mouth chens
has two heads above his collar his
and the one in his mouth and it was so
awful dude
because not because necessarily that the
pigeon died thank god jen's put him he
decapitated him like he was [ __ ]
thanos at the end of end game
uh that he he decapitated the pigeon
fine put him out of the misery
that was the good part thank you chens
for speeding this
up and we'd have to take it to a [ __ ]
pigeon place instead of that
this is the worst part chen's was under
a cactus have you ever been under a
cactus no because you don't have
a dog brain dogs don't give a [ __ ] about
what's above
below next to them at all because they
only want what the food is and they
don't even know what next to them
is they don't know what above or below
is but we do and what was above
chen's was a it was a [ __ ]
40 000 needles and 20 000 when in chens
and
dude kristen was trying to pull him out
like do surgery
i'm like how come we were gonna take the
pigeon to the pigeon place we can't take
the dog to the [ __ ] dog
place you gotta manually take these
[ __ ] things out
so the rest of the trip
but it took about two hours to get all
the pins out the rest of the trip
it would be like i in the middle of the
night i would just all of a sudden be ah
she's like what i'm like i got a [ __ ]
pin in me because chen's is everywhere
and they would just be falling out ah
just a [ __ ] cactus pin in my torso
ah she's like what's wrong the [ __ ]
chen
[ __ ] out another needle dude there's a
[ __ ] there was one in my uh
like face like neck face area
one in my torso and then one in my foot
i hope that pigeon was good
i hope that pigeon was good dude god
damn dude
isn't it crazy have you ever really
thought about how like
the circle of life is life consuming
other life
to eat like even vegans like you're
eating you're still eating plants like
these
are all [ __ ] living things that's
[ __ ] up that's one cruel joke dude
why can't we just be good on sand or
some [ __ ]
it's such a cruel joke that jesus christ
from up above made
and he was like let's make the world but
in this world if you were if
if if nothing was the world if the world
was nothing
if we were just consciousness right and
you said to another per
conscious consciousness if you were
consciousness
and you said to another [ __ ]
hey know what what
i'ma make a world besides all the whole
[ __ ] what's a world
well it's a what it's around and you
[ __ ] in a galaxy what are you talking
besides all that if you got up to the
point where you're like
and in this world your listening
consciousness yeah
in this world i'm gonna put people
and animals and living things there's
going to be amoebas
there's going to be a [ __ ] storm of life
okay
and all these things well most of them
are going to have consciousness
that's what we are we're going to put
things we're going to put us
in bodies some of them are going to be
real ugly we're going to call them boars
some of them are going to be handsome as
[ __ ] like lorenzo llamas
and antonio sabato jr and they're going
to walk around the earth
and the only way for them to live is to
take
one of the other things that are also
living
and put them inside of themselves that
consciousness would be like
dude i'm [ __ ] out of here man
i mean that's insane but we just accept
it because we're born in it i gotta tell
calvin that
and he's gonna he's already doing it i'm
up for great chicken twice today
scary [ __ ] dude it's the stuff that used
to keep me up when i was nine years old
and i would [ __ ] scream at my dad to
come in and my dad would say hey what's
up and i'd be like i'm scared he'd be
like of what and i'd be like everything
one time i said everything birds
he said you're scared of birds i said no
i'm just trying to explain you that i'm
scared of everything
and birds are part of everything god
what an annoying
child in person i am um
i don't know man
i had calvin i had a moment where i was
with dude this is the trippiest moment
so far as a father and uh
i had a moment where calvin was in the
pool
and i was in the pool with him and the
pool the pool was too cold
okay and i was in there though cause he
was able to blast this kid
his teeth were chattering and his lips
were purple and his hair was just all
matted he was just like
splashing the [ __ ] just [ __ ] drinking
water coughing almost crying and then
just off to the races again right
and there was a more i was lifting him
up and looking at him and i just had
this moment i looked at him
and he looked more like me that i had
ever seen he looked more like me than i
had ever noticed
ever and he already looks at me like
looks like me a lot if you've seen my
instagram whatever um
you you know that like the kid's
obviously mine he's got the [ __ ]
delia eyebrows but this
kid some about how he was cold and still
smiling but his hair was matted
it reminded me of when i was young and
in the bath and [ __ ] and when i would
look in the mirror
and i was holding him and i was looking
at him and i had
such a weirdly beautiful moment
and i will never forget it
you know how sometimes you have those
moments in life that
happen and they're so fun and so good
and you had no idea it was gonna happen
and sometimes they're very long it was
like oh that time
i went to my first mets game with my dad
and daryl strawberry
uh hit a grand slam and everybody jumped
up and started screaming and it was the
first inning and my dad had never seen a
grand slam so he [ __ ] jumped up and
started screaming and i started
crying and my dad looked out and said
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and i
said
you know what i can take that it's too
cold
i can take that everyone's too loud but
i
hate that they're all mad at me
okay and i remember that but who knows
when something like that is going to
happen that's going to carry you
carry with you through the rest of your
life right those moments are very
special
and those moments are awesome and you
don't know when they're going to happen
when they happen
boom whoops upside your head now that's
with you in your back pocket
this was one of those moments and i'll
never forget it and it was something so
simple as just holding him in the
[ __ ] pool
and i know you all have those moments
and that's awesome
and i love that you have those moments
um because those are
you know what those are your [ __ ]
moments dude
and nobody can take that [ __ ] from you
you know
you could take a [ __ ] sweater you
could take someone's
you know tools you could steal someone's
car
but you can't [ __ ] take a moment
that happens you can't take that and
that is beautiful
now that's enough of that [ __ ]
that's enough of that [ __ ] okay
um
there's a [ __ ] third property brother
did you know that
you know that there's a third property
brother
dude why are they keeping that from us
that's what i want to know
you got the [ __ ] two guys paul and
eric
what are their names probably i don't
know what their names are
paul and eric probably you got them
and they're twins and yeah they wear
shirts that are too tight and yeah they
got [ __ ] dockers on but they
do their thang and they do their thing
hard you see them go into these [ __ ]
houses and these houses look like [ __ ]
and they make these houses look okay and
from [ __ ] to okay
that's a lot that's a huge upswing
well we're actually gonna you know we'll
turn this fireplace
into something and with the leftover
money i've got to go into these people's
house and i have to tell them
that they can't have this fireplace
without skimping on another thing
so we can either get rid of the the
the dome wall or they're gonna have to
give up on some lighting fixtures now
let's go
and you're invested in a [ __ ]
dude aren't you you are
invested then a [ __ ] dude
do i look like the kind of guy who
watches home renovation shows
no but i am
i love this [ __ ] show and they're
twins dude
could hgtv ask for more
this [ __ ] was like a
it's great for a poster two twins and
[ __ ]
they probably say some [ __ ] like on the
poster fixing a house is
too bad we can't fix each other you know
what i mean i could think of these tag
lines all day
twins by design but not by you know what
i mean something right
when it comes to design we can but not
twins
i'd buy all the dvds if that was a
tagline by the way i'd give them my
money here's my wallet
but um there's a third one dude
imagine being the third one
you know what i'm talking about there's
two first of all
imagine being the third one to twins
non-famous twins twins
they got the [ __ ] dude they got you know
what they got they got
all the stares they got all the
attention they got all the [ __ ]
cool fun things oh there's a two-seater
who's gonna go on it
the two twins not the one of the twins
and one of the [ __ ] then the other
guy
the two twins are gonna go on and that
lonely ass other brother is just gonna
be like no go ahead it's okay
you guys go have fun i guess i will just
be over here pooping and no one will
clean my diaper
you guys got clean diapers all the time
huh you're forgotten about
because twins but do you know
what twins have even more so
than all of those things attention and
[ __ ]
cute outfits they've got each other dude
they've got each other their minds are
like one
you hear how many stories where the twin
dies and then the other twin dies is a
[ __ ] week later of a heart attack
can't take it dude you know
or you heard the one thing where you
punch one twin and the other one feels
it
you know that other brother's like i
wish i could feel that even though it's
pain it would make me connected
will someone clean that no okay
just standing there with a shitty diaper
no pain
they have each other that's what they
have
and then on top of that though
they're famous and have a show on hgtv
who's the third one that guy's my best
friend
by default i feel for that [ __ ]
i'm gonna look him up third property
brother
third by accident third
here we go
wow he is
younger oh dude you know what he looks
like a [ __ ] japanime version of the
other two that's what he looks like
he looks like the guy that no you know
what he looks like
he looks like the [ __ ] you start the
video game with one of the twins
and then when you get all of the money
and the upgrades you can upgrade to that
guy that's what he looked like
he's got his hair over there dude he's
emo
of course he's he has to be what's he
gonna wear [ __ ] button downs and [ __ ]
no
he's emo his name's jd
jd stands for just dreaming just
dreaming of a better life
[Laughter]
i wish i was a triplet just dreaming
of a better life yeah
jesus christ dude
wow he's in [ __ ] for sure
i wish i could build it i wish i could
sell it
[Music]
is there another one no there's three
okay dude give him a show
wow this is beautiful that this is a guy
oh here's this is their oh no that's a
different guy whatever dude
i would have loved it if did he like
they really wanted him to you to use him
and he just couldn't
he was just like so [ __ ] bad at his
job
jd yeah can you
he just like is well i don't know i feel
for the [ __ ] guy whatever
jd fight the good fight dude
this coffee is [ __ ] absolutely
terrible it's got cinnamon in it great
yeah
yay i don't like it like that yay um
[ __ ] [ __ ] man i can't believe i
skilled
i skilled a corpian i killed a scorpion
all right [ __ ] sometimes i talk like
foghorn leghorn man i killed a scorpion
um
i did something actually when i was in
arizona uh
we went to visit arizona i did something
last week where i was
we were going to get in and out i wanted
to go get in and out
you know what i do sometimes i get a
[ __ ] spur of the moment thing i
wanted to go
i wanted to go get in and out almost
threw up gonna keep it and not cut it
out because i respect you guys i want
you guys to know the real me almost
threw up
uh but i wanted to go get in and out
and i say to the lady i say hey wanna go
get in and out and she goes like this
[ __ ] yeah i'll eat in and out and so i'm
like all right cool what will be awesome
is
we'll get the in and out we'll bring it
back
and then we'll eat it while watching
naked and afraid
think of a better night you can't
think of a better night newsflash you
can't
you got the best burgers and you got the
craziest best trash tv show
these people might die on that show
eating burgers while watching people
fight for their lives
and try to find some [ __ ] well
burgers
that's amazing that's an amazing night
dude she's like let's go
and so we go and we get in and out no i
about
on the way to in and out she says oh
it's no target
i'm like oh yeah there's just kind of
targets everywhere anyway
what do you want she's like let's get i
want this and definitely no fries
because i'll eat yours and i'm just like
i'll get you an extra fries you know how
like [ __ ]
women do that thing where they're just
like i don't want i don't want this
i'll just no i want all of the fries
that came with my fries and i want not
one less of those fries
because fries are two dollars so if you
even want
three fries let's just spring and get
you a whole stash
yeah so um we go
and we get to the in and out and we eat
and we get the in and out
and she goes like this can we go to
target and i just sit back
and relax because i know it's closed
already
i'm chilling and i can't wait to be like
sweetheart it's 9 30.
so i say it and she says so and i say
sweetheart stores close around nine
and she goes like this
not target and i said but target is a
store
it definitely closes around nine and she
says target closes at 11
and i say that's not possible and i know
it's not possible
because if it is possible and if that is
true
today's the last day of my life
so we google it and lo and behold
the [ __ ] [ __ ] spanking target is open
till 11.
so i say i really don't want to go to
target
and then i think about all the work i've
done in therapy and i think about the
couple's therapy and i think about not
being selfish
and acquiescing and letting kind of
leading with love what do they call it
you know and i say
i want you to know i don't want to go to
target but
if you really want to go to target
then we'll go to target and i'm like
this is great
because i've already stated i don't want
to go to target
she's going to know that right take that
in
feel badly and say you know what never
mind
and you know what she says i really want
to go
so we [ __ ] but i said but the fun
thing was to eat the burgers while
watching naked and afraid and she says
no it's but i want to go to target we
can eat it in the car and it'll be fun
to eat in the car and like fun to eat
burgers and the car cars gonna stink
like [ __ ] we're gonna be all messy we're
gonna have enough napkins they never
give you enough napkins
and she's like come on and so we sit and
we in the [ __ ] car we go to target
and she's like isn't this fun
and guess what it wasn't fun and that's
the end of the story dude
but i led with love and uh you know
i i'm i made her happy and that was
worth it dude
was it you know what i mean it was worth
it
that is worth it was it but it was dude
what was it um
yeah dude you gotta lead with love you
know sometimes you just gotta sit and
eat burgers in your
in your [ __ ] car instead of watching
[ __ ]
naked people running around africa while
you're enjoying that's the thing i like
to be eating and watching the show i
like because
you get the two sensations
you know you know what i'm talking about
you get the eating and the fun with the
flavor and then also
you get to watch it and stimulate
she wanted target though dude so we were
in [ __ ] belly full of burgers in
target
so gross ew dude
belly full of burgers and target
that's like a [ __ ] what's it what's
it called wha who's that
adam duretz singer counting crows
and we were in target with a belly full
of burgers round here
[Applause]
burgers in our guts
round here
around here
oops we're back we're back baby we'll do
it live [ __ ] it we'll do it live we had
to take a break
because i was so hot and uh i don't know
man sometimes i just get in my head you
know what i mean and i [ __ ] i [ __ ]
went dude how oh you know what did
happen though and yes i just thought of
this right now is the [ __ ]
and i don't i don't even have it in my
notes so you know it's a hot [ __ ]
button issue dude the oscars
who watches the oscars dude the oscars
[ __ ] suck
period that's it that's it dude have you
seen
the [ __ ] oscars lately and after you
answer no realize because they suck
dude the oscars man you can't even
[ __ ] can't they not go now isn't it
virtual now
hey what's worse than the oscars actors
just [ __ ] patting each other on the
back when everyone's coughing
and dying dude everyone's dying and the
actors are just like
i really wanted to do this round because
it really spoke to me
and it's really [ __ ] no dude stay
home
dude if i ever and i will and
never get nominated for an oscar but if
i ever did
and i know that if i did we would be
living in the same world
as [ __ ] goddamn
you know what's his name is that this
would
i just know i will never win an oscar
dude
you know period i may never be in
another [ __ ] movie
[Music]
however dude if i ever was
i'm not going dude and i'm telling you
that right [ __ ] now
right now dude i'm not going
go ahead go ahead man put me in a movie
nominate the [ __ ] out of me dude i'll be
up there with [ __ ]
uh don cheadle edward james gelmost and
[ __ ]
whoever the [ __ ] and i'll be sitting
there and i
you can nominate the [ __ ] out of me i
could get nominated you know what put me
in five movies
nominate me in all of them cause i tell
you right now i'm a good actor dude
do you want you want something new you
got something new and incredible
you want something [ __ ] silly but
still like a little bit heartwarming is
that what you want
what do you want you want a guy who kind
of sounds different but also walks a
little bit with a limp
i can [ __ ] kill it i don't know it
sounds silly but i'm serious dude
oh yeah dude put me in a [ __ ] movie
i'll kill it dude i'll cry in scenes
where there's no crying necessary man
i'll do the kind of crying that [ __ ]
leonardo dicaprio did
where the uh boogers come out of his
nose and basketball diaries and you're
like how did he even [ __ ] do that
was this did they just catch him crying
in his hotel room and they shot this
scene
i'll do those kinds of crying in a scene
in a [ __ ] supermarket
do you understand i'll do cryings when
there wasn't any cryings
and and and at first thought you'd be
like well it's too much for this scene
but by the end of the scene i'll throw
in an ad-lib and it'll be like oh [ __ ]
it actually came back around and he made
enough sense
i get why he's crying now and that's the
director saying that that's todd
phillips sitting in his chair like oh
okay
i'll do [ __ ] crazy cryings and i'll
take the scenes
where you're supposed to cry
and i won't cry that's putting your
balls on the table you understand
and i will just [ __ ] murder that
screenplay
you understand
if i ever have to [ __ ] do a movie
where i have to pull a gun on my cop i
gotta pull a gun on somebody
you see the fear in my eyes too though
dude you don't just see me pull a gun on
somebody
and i'm a rough and tumbler i'm not just
that you see
you get the close-up and you see behind
my eyes you see uh oh he's [ __ ]
actually i could see he's scared
that's the kind of [ __ ] acting i
would do
so i'll do five different movies where
i'm the cop with the fear behind his
eyes
i know i'm going to supermarket [ __ ]
weeping and i'm sitting here and i'm
doing a scene where i'm supposed to be
crying but i'm acting like a badass
but behind the face you see what i'm
really all about nominate me five times
in the same [ __ ] year where i'm
against myself
i won't [ __ ] show up i won't show up
five times i'll send in
five letters to the [ __ ] oscar board
and i'll say
hey guys i can't come because this [ __ ]
[ __ ] blows chunks
and i won't do an email i'll type it out
[ __ ] that i'll write it out
i'll write it out five different times
and i'll send it to the oscars
nominate someone else because this [ __ ]
isn't for that i get so
[ __ ] wow i didn't expect this i did
not expect this at oh
i don't know why i'm making them all
british cause they all are dude they
give all the roles to [ __ ] british
dudes
i didn't expect us at oh really you
didn't you were nominated dude
there was a pretty damn good chance he's
gonna get it it'd be weird as [ __ ] if my
dog chen's got it i'll tell you that
he could not expect it but you
[ __ ] that dude remember when colin firth
one i
lied for king speech that's the kind of
acting i would do dude
stuttering overboard stuttering where
it's so good
where you're like whoa he really made a
choice but it's still good because the
director knew what it was up you know
that's why i was watching you know i was
watching the other day naked gun that
movie naked gun
and it's so [ __ ] good besides the
fact that it's funny it's so good and
the reason why it's so good
is because everybody in that movie
whether an actor
writer director they all knew what
they were doing they all knew the tone
that they were doing
they were dancing around the tone all of
them and they were all part of the dance
the director hit the [ __ ] wide shot
when the people were you know doing what
they were supposed to be doing in the
wide shot
leslie nielsen you know you say like oh
leslie nielsen was the best at that and
he was
but credit doesn't get enough to the
director they were all on the same tone
dude
mr poopy pence when he said that
dude oh we could be mature adults right
isn't that right mr
poopy pence dude they knew what they
were all doing
that's why i [ __ ] think the matrix is
so good yeah it's a [ __ ] ridiculous
movie if you just describe it to
somebody but they all knew what they
were doing you could make any movie
as long as everybody in the movie all
knew what they were doing
within the confines of that [ __ ]
movie
that's why matrix two and three [ __ ]
blow donkey they don't blow donkeys
number three blows donkey dicks doll
because they got out of control and they
let the studios control it matrix one
nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah it was 70
million dollars for a budget but they
were like okay
well these were trusky brothers they
know what they're doing i guess probably
two three two number one was such a big
hit okay two this is what we do okay
three is what we do
and then you got two [ __ ] albino
white twins getting hit by cars and cars
are flipping over them and you're like
man can we just have neo go whoa
or i know kung fu you know what i mean
um but yeah dude what was i talking
about the [ __ ] um
not naked gun before the naked gun
oscars yeah when they did that [ __ ]
thing
on uh on on
i made fun of it on tick tock but
the the i made fun of it on my tick tock
but the [ __ ]
when abc put out that [ __ ]
what do the oscars mean to me and
everybody was just british on it i'm
just gonna play it on my tick tock
because that was what it was
that was what the uh that's the audio of
it
watch the oscars because
first of all didn't finish hey look they
cut to another person dude
let the guy [ __ ] finish i watch the
oscars because
and then another person you know what
that's like that's like hey
hey white guy move over
[Music]
you're gonna make me whine i watch the
oscars because i love cinnamon
[Music]
i know i will see somebody like
me being recognized
that they've achieved mm-hmm
i love
[Music]
it's a quote from maryland i'm going to
be a great movie star
someday wow you know the balls
everyone's dying um that lady
who [ __ ] said i love crying that lady
is so good at acting
if you watch that uh what's that movie
where was it where the guy from doctor
who
the show was from doctor who is in it
she's in that
in season one it's called like
bridgetown or some [ __ ]
it's a real british thing it's with the
guy from doctor who
and [ __ ] this is how i describe
goddamn tv shows and movies now
i don't know what it's called
broadchurch yes he got it dude his mind
his mind isn't deteriorating as much as
he thought his mind swooped in dude
it's called wow i forget it again
broadchurch dude she's in that and she's
so [ __ ] good
she does one scene where she is crying
and she just she realizes something
like about her husband and she she's
crying it's like
and she starts dry heaving and you're
like oh my god this actress
that woman give the oscars all to her
and make the oscars five minutes and
give them all to her
god she's good i love crying
and then there's [ __ ] a-rod you know
god people are
different dude you know what i'm talking
about
how the [ __ ] is a-rod a person and also
that lady who's lying we love i love
crying like what
then you got a rod over here just like
she broke up with me
no i i don't know dude i'm just making
fun man look i
this is the thing man people watch this
podcast sometimes they become an [ __ ]
they don't understand i'm a real person
i get it dude
lead with love and i'm serious though
like i love you know i love that [ __ ] i
love that i love that people go to
you know a-rod is people's heroes like
you know kids are like i want to be like
that guy you know
not so much because the steroids but
because he hit so many home runs and he
[ __ ] achieve something you know
and that's great um
it's great
keep telling kristen to get the coffee
the regular coffee and she gets
a holiday blend and it's [ __ ] april
so that's great
good not only do i not want the holiday
blend coffee in december i don't want it
in april
100 tenfold um
so that's what's up i don't know man
i [ __ ] forget why couldn't i think of
the guy's broad church name why can't i
think of the name broadchurch
dude i'm 41 and i'm just deteriorating
man
i'm trying to why can't i think of that
i saw a whole season abroad church why
could i not think of broad church why
can't i think of the lead actor's name
in broad church
when i know who it is and i can't
remember it
and then when you start you know when
you can't think of something and you're
starting to think of something
you can't think of something and then
you worrying about
how come you can't think of it makes it
harder to remember
in the first place and now you're just
well well gone
dude one time i was doing a show
and i was and i had to go on stage and
they called my name
and actually no when i here's
when i saw the when i got to the venue
it was a bigger venue
with like stadium seating and [ __ ]
and i noticed that in the back entrance
you where you go where the
loading dock is the the garage to the
loading dock was
coming down and it was down it was down
and it was stopped down halfway
and i was like oh when i go
up into that opening i have to
remember that the the door is down
so i don't hit my head
i have to duck under the door to make
sure to do that when i go on stage
so i was like don't forget chris you
ever do that in your own head you're
like okay but you know how usually
forget this is what i do to myself i say
hey all right chris though you know how
you usually forget stuff don't do it
this time
i was like okay chris deal
an hour passes and sure enough
crystallia and
dude i i didn't just hit my head on it
i was excited to go on stage
and i leapt my head into the [ __ ]
under part of the just it was like i
didn't have that conversation it was
like i didn't
see it in the first place smashed my
head
so hard that i had to like back up
against a wall because i was like am i i
wasn't like oh i'm gonna pass out but i
was like i was at the point where i was
like
i better hold the the wall
because when you think you're when you
think you're gonna pass out it's already
too late
so i was like let me just hold the wall
in case i think i'm gonna pass out
okay the moment passed and i was like
[ __ ] it i gotta go on stage
and i was like thank god it wasn't that
bad
because if i was knocked out or if it
[ __ ] knocked a screw loose
i wouldn't be able to remember my act so
i get on stage i start doing my act
and about 14 minutes in i start thinking
oh i forgot that i hit my head
that's awesome it means it didn't do any
damage
i'm just up here business as usual
talking about [ __ ] whatever i was
talking about
and i thought all that and since i
thought all that
i then thought whoa because i'm still
doing my act
as i'm thinking that i think whoa better
get back
on track and start thinking about my act
because i'm talking to an audience and
then i was like
but don't think
too hard about what you're going to say
[Laughter]
because you don't normally do that when
you're up on stage
so don't over compensate just because
you hit your head
and you want to make sure that you don't
have any brain damage or something right
so i start backing off of focusing on
every word that i'm saying
because that's what's more normal but at
that point it was already
way too late so i think
well i better not just forget what i'm
to say next
and sure enough i just stopped talking
and i couldn't remember what i was going
to say next not because i hit my
[ __ ] head because i was worried about
what if
this did brain damage or some [ __ ]
so i stopped and i was like i got
probably you know this happens in
sometimes when you're doing stand-up
you'll forget something for three
seconds you're like i got like three or
four seconds
nobody's gonna notice until like the
fifth or sixth second
i'll get it i'll get it back within five
seconds you just retrace your [ __ ]
and i was trying to retrace my [ __ ] in
my mind three four seconds five seconds
six seconds go i'm not saying [ __ ] i'm
not
saying anything i'm just on stage just
like
in my head i'm like re just rewind it
dude
retrace it you got hit it's fine you
gotta hit the head it doesn't matter
what were you talking about it dear
and i [ __ ] tried and and then and
then i gave up
i gave up on stage thousands of people
there and i just said
hey guys i [ __ ] got to be honest with
you
i hit my
i hit my head so [ __ ] hard before i
got understand
and i was worried that it was gonna like
[ __ ] me up and now cause i'm worried
that was gonna [ __ ] me up i can't
remember what the [ __ ] i was gonna say
in my act
it's not cause i have memory loss it's
just because i'm like thinking too hard
about how i hit my head
everyone starts laughing and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] was i
just talking about and then people on in
the audience were like
you're talking about this and i was like
oh yeah and i was like i'm just gonna
[ __ ]
let me just back up i'm gonna back up
like a minute and i'm just gonna start
doing my act and i'll be able to get
into it from there
and so i backed up started talking about
[ __ ] that i already talked about saying
it word for word
like the whole trick of comedy is like
hey i'm thinking all this stuff up on my
own by myself right now
and even though everyone knows you're
not well some idiots think you're making
up everything new every hour
but even though everyone kind of knows
that this is an act they just buy that
maybe it's just some guy having a good
time at a party right
and uh so i back up and i start doing
the same [ __ ] thing
and then i get to the point where i
forgot and i got it i'm locked in
because now i'm not thinking about it
and i do the part where i stopped and
everyone's like [ __ ] everyone cheered
they're like hey
you [ __ ] did it and i was like just
because i hit my head
thank you you can't stop me and i have
all you to thank
you know it was a real cool moment to it
but that i think that that was the
beginning really
of the end because that was the first
moment where i was like ah [ __ ]
my head can get to me and now
i'm like what's broad church for like a
minute and i always go back to that
moment i'm like is this like another one
of those moments where i [ __ ] hit my
head and i'm just overthinking or do i
really have alzheimer's
broad church
anyway the [ __ ] thing is broadchurch
and the lady in it acts so good
and so is the guy he's like really
famous in britain that's the guy's name
i should remember broadchurch it's like
ray something
let me look this up and then i'm going
to go cast
he played doctor who danny david tennant
why is that funny dude she's laughing
why is it funny
it's ray something it's david tennant
dude it's it's whatever dude it's david
tennant it's not ray
oh yeah remember this cast dude olivia
coleman is that the lady she's so good
she's the one that's probably going to
win at austria this year or something or
she did
oh the favorite right i love because i
love
crying
dude there's a scene in broadchurch
where she figures find something out
and just starts dry heaving and i'm like
hats off olivia buckman or whatever the
[ __ ] your name is hats off
when you get to that real [ __ ] vomit
level of acting
that's it all right that's it dude
free shipping on our on our on the whole
world
storewide crystallia.com free shipping
and then also
um it's for the next 24 hours
free shipping and uh it's but it's
domestic it's only domestic so if you
live in in scotland
uh you're [ __ ] i don't know what to
tell you
that's it for this episode on youtube
for the unedited
extended version go to our patreon and
sign up patreon.comcrystalia thanks for
listening
[Music]
thank you